simon va acheter des plantes au match le
stationnement est plein simon est prêt
c'est un peu tôt il décide de se garer
dans le stationnement d'un resto minutes
situé en face à son retour quelques
minutes plus tard sa voiture a disparu
un remorqueur stationner un peu plus
loin lui fait alors signe sinon on
s'approche et le remorqueur réformes
qu'il a déplacé sa voiture
le remorqueur exige 65 dollars compte
pour lui dire où se trouve son véhicule
le remorqueur est il dans son droit
non légalement il n'a pas le droit de
retenir le véhicule pour exiger de se
faire payer
pourquoi parce qu'il n'a conclu aucune
entente signé aucun contrat avec simon
simon peut donc exiger que le remorqueur
lui révèle où il a déplacé son véhicule
tout ce que peut faire le remorqueur
c'est de tenter d'obtenir l'adresse de
ciment pour lui faire parvenir une
facture le fin mot de l'histoire
ne soyez pas à leurs remarques de ceux
qui veulent vous intimider